americans will spend an estimated 200  billion dollars in gift cards this year  but you know a big chunk of that money  goes to waste a new survey from bankrate  finds half of u.s  adults have unused gift cards vouchers  or store credits yeah look in your  wallet right now the average person is  sitting on  116 dollars and many times the money's  never spent  ted rossman is with bankrate.com  half of us have lost value at some point  either because we lost the card or it  expired or maybe the  business went out of business before we  had a chance to use it  experts say there's no reason to let the  value on a gift card go to waste  there are plenty of websites that will  offer cash for them  and if they're these include raise card  cash and give cash  they allow you to sell the card and  receive around 80 to 90 percent of the  value  another option give the card to someone  else even if there's a small remainder  left